you need a million Muslim March in
Washington with national coverage to
speak out against Isis so the whole
world can see it we don't see the mill
million Muslim March in Washington I
wish we would the counter-argument that
some heifers
provided about a million man march is
that it's just to appease the people
that are against Islam it's not actually
going to change the recruitment of
groups like Isis the facts show that in
the ever since 9/11 Muslims have become
more and more vocal and more and more
visible in their outrage and their
condemnation and in their confrontation
of group sex Isis but yet we still have
people to say when will the modern
Muslims finally speak up against
terrorism
[Music]